hello hello hello hello today's video
blog is brought to you from my little
sister's bedroom that's not weird is it
so I've come home to bath to visit my
little sister and my mum because it's my
little sister's birthday today and I
wanted to come and celebrate the fact
that she's still alive with her 15 years
going well done Brady and I wanted to
film in Brady's bedroom today because
this used to be my bedroom if you could
believe it I mean it looks very very
different now with all of the kind of
fashion stuff and it smells like girl
it's very frilly in things it's a bit
weird for me but this is the room that I
made the vast majority of the videos
that are on my youtube channel so I had
to I felt like I had to be here so yes
hello yesterday I felt the urge to do
something a little bit different and so
I made a vlog brothers esque thoughts
from places star video about bath or am
at the moment my home town and I'm gonna
share that with you now
so I hope you like it and stuff alright
bye so I woke up at 8 a.m. in my little
sister's old bedroom which is why
everything is purple and covered with
stars and about an hour later I finally
got myself out of bed and I went into
town with my mum being nice enough to
give me a lift and this is well the
first thing you notice about barf is
that it just looks bloody lovely as seen
here and here and here and here and
definitely here and you'll also notice
that it's full of tourists coming to
look at all of these briefings as seen
here and here and well just about
everywhere really but I wasn't really
interested in looking at the baths that
the tourists would come to see and so
instead I went on a tour of all of the
places in the city that have some kind
of meaning to me personally for example
this is where I was born after 38 hours
of my mum tried to get me out this is
the first house I ever lived in this was
my nursery school where I accidentally
killed a goldfish once by feeding it
grass this is where I swallowed my first
bit of chewing gum this is the news
agents that I got banned from when I
accidentally broke something in there
this was my route to primary school
every day I used to be religious and
this is the church that I used to go to
this was the elephant that I used to
ride in my local park the same local
park where my friend Jonathan broke his
arm
this was the monument that I played
football in front of my last every day
of primary school but I couldn't get any
closer because there was a gate in the
way this was my secondary school where I
learnt education or something this is
the road I used to walk up every day to
get to secondary school this is the shop
that I used to steal Mars bars from when
I was a kid this is an alley that I went
down once to try a cigarette it made me
feel really ill by the way definitely
not a hobby I wanted to take up this is
where I went wants to try and do some
graffiti with some friends and I was
really bad at it this is the skatepark
that I used to frequent during my
bad-boy phase and this is a kid dropping
into the spine which I tried to do once
but I fell off and then I never went to
gate morning again this is the game
station that I queued outside of at
midnight with my mum for the launch of
the Nintendo Wii this is where I first
got recognized off of YouTube by a guy
passing me on his bike this is where I
went to go and sit and chat with my
friends during PE when we were meant to
be doing cross-country running and this
is where I had my first proper kiss as I
was walking around getting fur do all of
these little places that have some
meaning to me I kept on getting weird
looks from people one person in
particular this lady was completely
flummoxed as to why I found the entrance
to this carpark so interesting saying
that's nice isn't it as you walk past
but I'm sure that she just like everyone
has their own quirky versions of their
hometowns that they be able to
appreciate if they took the time out to
do so math has already changed quite a
lot since I've left but the baffle that
exists inside my head my bath hasn't
really changed at all if you ever get
the chance to just wander around your
hometown for no reason other than just
to be a bit nostalgic I would definitely
recommend it by the way did you know the
bath has a mineral water hospital I I
really I don't understand why mineral
water needs a zone a hospital so if
anyone could explain that to me that'll
be really good thanks also here are some
sheep okay bye you've just had the
almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool